ladies and gentlemen at long last after
years
of talking and calling out these day
traders one of them
has called me out cameron foose who you
may know because i made a video about
him
a few months ago i'm excited to say that
he finally responded and i can't wait to
watch
with you guys let's take a little peek
and see what we're in for woo i'm
excited he's going to address the
concerns
guys i may be i may be taking an l here
i may it might be the first l i've ever
taken in my life
i'm ready to take my lumps okay cameron
give it to me but first before we get
into
his whole his whole take down let me
remind you
about what i originally said about
cameron so first i called him out for a
fake woke transformation successful
people
aren't happy happy people are successful
wow where he realized that suddenly he
didn't need all this money and flashy
lifestyle because
honestly he's still selling the same
success he was before
but recently he's just reinvented
himself under the guise of minimalism
and being like super tan which
objectively
hey it's true it's true man but he's
still selling the same dream to people
that he said
he was no longer going to be selling and
specifically recently it's taken the
form of a
forex bot which automatically trades
forex for you and achieves
wild returns it's basically the same bs
passive income claims we've been hearing
forever that you can make above average
returns in the market with
zero extra work or risk but instead of
being explained by
drop shipping or youtube automation or
better yet magic
the reason we hear this time is of
course robots did it now to be clear
trading robots do exist but bad trading
robots also exist
and robots in ar are buzz words that
people often use to make crazy claims
and not get called out for it like if i
tell you that i could make you 20
a month in the market consistently
you're never going to believe me
but there's a bunch of people promising
that right now with an
ai expert make a wild claim robots did
it baby so in the last video i pointed
all this out and said that if cameron
really had a bot
that he could make two percent a week
with like he was advertising in his link
tree
he could have stuck a hundred thousand
dollars in the account and become a
billionaire within 10 years
the fact that he's not doing that
instead selling the bot to you
should tell you everything you need to
know about the actual usefulness of this
bot i wrapped up the video by pointing
out that the broker he was using was
unregulated and therefore dangerous and
overall it was a pretty
normal coffeezilla video taking down yet
another one of these
millionaire day traders that's been
around basically forever so with that
context out of the way let's take a look
at his video
and see what he has to say about my
arguments and how he argues against this
forex trading bots i can't believe i'm
actually
talking about them because they're so
controversial and stupid i even got
coffeezilla coming after me
making a whole video about me talking
about forex trading bots and i haven't
even made a youtube video about it wait
wait a second you definitely
did in my video i'm literally responding
to your
youtube video about iq trade the
the little trading bot you have this is
my first one but i don't blame them i
actually haven't even watched the video
it's probably pretty funny
wait what you're responding to my video
without
watching my video what is this dude
is this the response it's just you
didn't watch it and you're just gonna
blindly make a video defending yourself
without watching my video this is insane
what that's why i haven't even made a
video about
our iq trade bot that i'm partnered with
again yeah you did he's gonna say i'm
partnered with iq trade
but that's fancy language for i
co-founded
iq trade and that's why i am behind this
company and i am the co-founder of iq
trade
wait are you behind it or did you found
it there's a big difference i'm a big
fan of the product
also i created the the product that's
really important because he's going to
talk about how he uses iq trade and he
just likes the bot but to be clear
he co-founded the company you know it's
like it's like being the inventor of
the iphone and being like yeah i really
like the iphone not biased or anything i
really like it
because we were beta testing making sure
everything was set before i could
actually come out here and comfortably
talk about this
even though copyzilla somehow found out
about it through my
instagram or something i don't know you
made a video about it
this is not complicated yeah i talked
about it briefly in another youtube
video
and it is went full-blown on me again
hate to be
a little critical of you cam but you're
saying i went ape on you but you
you didn't watch the video so
i don't know what to say i could have
said you were a wonderful dude in that
video and you'd have no idea
which is [ __ ] hilarious coffeezilla
i'm a fan i think you're
funny i take no offense i would make a
youtube video about talking [ __ ] about
forex trading bots as well but now
oddly enough i'm actually using one but
only because i tested it and it was
actually making me money
ah this is really important guys he
would be making a video about how big of
a scam
trading robots were except he used it
and it's making him so much money
or is it because he co-founded the
trading robot
i mean i mean guys
i always thought selling overpriced
courses was a scam
and then i started one uh and then i
realized they're totally great i mean
that line of reasoning is so bad like
you're literally saying
hey i've always said that these things
were a scam but then i built my own
version of the scam
and it isn't a scam anymore so watching
through the rest of this video
i'm sort of amazed at the uh cognitive
dissonance because he seems to
anticipate
just how ridiculous it is for someone
who's been talking trash about
forex bots forever to suddenly flip
around and make one
and he also anticipates how ridiculous
his whole scheme sounds but he doesn't
even
try to cover for it if you followed me
for the last
17 years of trading you would know that
i've always been a big proponent of
talking [ __ ] about forex and especially
talking
about automated trading because that
sounds absolutely ridiculous
listen if that actually worked everybody
would be making money and we'd all be
rich
and nobody would have to be doing
anything yeah so
what's your argument against that
because you'd think
i could press play right now and he'd
give me a good argument
for why his bot is different instead the
argument is
her der um robots are less emotional
than people
here's the problem with humans as
traders is one we are
emotional wrecks especially when it
comes to money in greed the good thing
about a forex trading bot
if you set it up correctly and if you
have the risk parameters set
to protect yourself there's no emotions
involved you give them
a set of rules and they actually follow
it and they don't break those rules
sometimes those rules can be broken if i
seem stunned right now it's because
i'm i'm in awe of the ability to
both like say why it's a scam be like
yeah automated trading is ridiculous
if it were real oh we'd all be no one
would be working like how could this
exist
and then also simultaneously be selling
automated trading
without ever defending yourself it's
incredible look i am stunned i am i'm
blown away
and the worst part of all of this is
that he shills this
unregistered broker again we talked
about this in the last video
he pitches you on something called hey
forex an
unregulated forex broker so not only are
you paying cameron 125
a month for this ridiculous unproven bot
but you're also told that cameron has
partnered with hey forex as their broker
what is up guys brief interruption here
i got some big news
iconic fx and cam foose has just
partnered up with hey
forex.com the number one trading broker
in the game and let me tell you why
first of all all of you guys want low
deposits we got low deposits all you
guys want big leverage we got 500 to one
and not only is this a forex broker you
can trade forex you can trade crypto you
can trade stocks you can trade cfds
which means you can trade gold
silver oil basically every asset never
miss a trade again
by partnering up with us and joining hey
forex broker i just joined as well
now this is super important nothing he
said
is that great 500 to one leverage will
get you
wrecked in the market people don't know
that getting getting those kind of
account leverages
it's so easy to blow up your account but
as you'll find out
that's not that big of a deal they kind
of want you to blow up your account
in america there's limits on how much
leverage you can offer
offer customers because people will
inevitably blow up their accounts if you
offer them too much
there's regulation around this issue and
then there's this point about low
deposits so who are we appealing to i
guess
poor people with low deposits they can
put in that's who you're appealing to
with this forex broker
none of this makes up for the fact that
they are unregulated
unregulated brokers are never to be
trusted if you take anything from
coffeezilla it's lack of regulation
in banking or finance is a bad thing
ladies and gentlemen it's how
con man thrive who's behind it nobody
knows
right let's say tomorrow they freeze
your assets what are you gonna do
well your only option is to go to saint
vincent and the grenadines a caribbean
offshore tax haven
you literally have to fly there and try
to beg these people for your money back
this is where it's located
on a world map ladies and gentlemen
good luck let me just say that good luck
and you could be mad at cameron foose
but really you should be mad at yourself
for falling for one of these
unregistered brokers so the point is why
would cameron be doing this why would he
partner
purposely with an unregulated broker
who's using the same location as many
other scam forex companies
this is really important offshore
caribbean islands are
constantly listed as the location of
scam
finance companies whether it be forex
whether it be crypto
whatever in just one list of scam
finance companies
i found six other companies known to be
fraudulent
that we're listed as being at st
vincent's and the grenadines
so why would cameron partner with an
unregulated exchange well the answer
might be in their affiliate program
where they offer
revenue sharing with the affiliate
because every time you trade on a forex
there's obviously a fee for that trade a
spread on that trade
and the exchange makes a profit if you
get wiped out from a margin call
whatever
the exchange is making money right and
when they make that money
they offer affiliates a whopping 30
commission on all of those trades
doesn't matter the amount traded
30 goes to your account ladies and
gentlemen so the more you trade the more
fees there are the more fees there are
the more money the exchange
makes and the more money the exchange
makes the more money the affiliate makes
who in this case is cameron so are you
guys getting it yet
cameron is financially incentivized for
you to trade a whole bunch and sign up
with hey forex who's gonna split that
money with them so then combine that
with the fact
that cameron wants you to sign up with a
trading bot
which can trade as often as iq trade
wants which he co-founded so no matter
what happens
he wins if you get wiped out he wins he
gets kickbacks from hey forex
and iq trade if you get lucky and make
money cameron also wins and he gets
kickbacks
even if hey forks refuses to give your
money back cameron
still makes money it's such a ridiculous
scheme that it would almost be laughable
if i didn't know that people are
definitely probably putting their money
here
and then unfortunately this guy sits
back and profits but maybe you shouldn't
listen to me guys all this talk about
affiliate schemes and offshore
unregulated brokers i mean after all
guys
coffeezilla videos according to cameron
foose are just full of a fan base
who are all the losers who tried to
escape the nine to five
and failed gave up and are bitter so
don't listen to me guys be a winner
don't be like those bitter losers who
work nine to five jobs
instead you need to be like cameron
foose because if you watch this channel
there's a very good chance according to
cameron foose that you are a
a bitter loser but maybe it's not just
my fans that are
bitter losers maybe it's a cameron's
fans actually because in this video he
uploaded
he had to delete all the comments
and remove them because apparently
they're getting so brutal
that he now there's just one comment on
the video and it's just cameron there's
24 000 views and only one comment
because apparently
all the other ones are being deleted
maybe maybe his fans are also bitter
guys
bitter perhaps because their icon
cameron foose the legendary day trader
sold them out
for a quick cash crap look all in all i
would say i'm disappointed in cameron
he had a chance to actually address
concerns about his uh
sketchy bot forex partnership and
instead
he chose to ignore criticism double down
and delete comments
and not really address any of my video
because
he didn't watch any of my video
if he had maybe he would have had
something uh more interesting to say
instead it was just another
sales pitch for iq trade which uh
is not his this bot that he just happens
to be you know interested in
he co-founded the bot he makes money
when you
but get into it he makes money when you
go to hey forex an
unregulated broker in some offshore tax
haven which good luck getting your money
back from that
so i don't know all in all this doesn't
any none of this sounds like the actions
of a successful and well-meaning day
trader but that's just me
i don't know i'd love to hear what you
guys think out of this exchange
who won who lost did cameron foose take
us down a peck
are you one of these coffeezilla bitter
losers
who just works a nine to five all day
let me know in the comments below and
uh that's basically it i'll see you guys
in the next one